und unser usa-korrespondent in den usa
beobachtet in die lage elmar theveßen
schönen guten morgen nach washington
also was ist dort jetzt genau passion
nach deutschland was ist dort jetzt
genau passiert was ist bekannt
also am montagmorgen um 9 uhr ortszeit
in marl lago in florida das ist der
golfclub in dem donald trump eben auch
lebt er hat doch da ein haus
sind fbi agenten rund ein dutzend in
zivilkleidung auf das gelände gekommen
haben einlass begehrt sind auch vom
secret service der normalerweise
beschützt hereingelassen worden und
haben dann das haus durchsucht darunter
haben sie nicht nur räumlichkeiten
angeschaut sondern haben ganz offenbar
auch im privatbüro von donald trump
seinen safe geöffnet regelrecht
aufgebrochen und durchsucht die ganze
aktion dauerte bis in den abend hinein
am montag und wir wüssten vielleicht von
alledem nichts wenn ich donald trump
persönlich eben in dieser erklärung
diese informationen an die
öffentlichkeit gegeben hätte er hat sich
eben empört dass so etwas gegen ihn
stattfindet und er bekommt mittlerweile
schützenhilfe von vielen
republikanischen anführern der partei
die behaupten dass er eine politische
hexenjagd aber wir wissen mittlerweile
dass das ganze auf einem
durchsuchungsbefehl basierte der von
einem richter unterschrieben wurde das
bedeutet es tut ein richter nur wenn
eben starke konkrete hinweise auf eine
straftat möglicherweise auch eine gefahr
für die nationale sicherheit vorhanden
ist aber so etwas wie das ist in der
geschichte amerikas noch nie passiert
gegen einen präsidenten oder ex
präsidenten berichtet wird auch über
dokumente die jump wohl nach seiner
amtszeit angeblich mit nach florida in
sein haus gebracht haben soll was
vermutet man da über die hintergründe
ja darum scheint es wirklich zu gehen im
januar hat man bereits 15 kartons mit
dokumenten und anderen
gegenständen aus malaga abgeholt die
trump dann herausgerückt hat so kann man
es glaube ich sagen die muss er
mitgenommen haben als er das weiße haus
im jahr 2021 verlassen hatte in diesen
kartons haben die agenten und eben auch
das nationalarchiv dem normalerweise
alle dokumente übergeben werden müssen
nach einer präsidentschaft offenbar auch
eine reihe von vertraulichen dokumenten
gefunden und diese durchsuchung jetzt
basiert eben auf den ermittlungen der
verdacht ist da dass möglicherweise tom
versucht hat streng geheime dokumente
verschwinden zu lassen oder
aufzubewahren was immer ja damit
vielleicht machen wollte deswegen jetzt
die durchsuchung und es deutet vieles
darauf hin dass die ermittlungen sich
eben weiter konkretisieren denn die
fbi-agentin wussten sehr genau wonach
sie suchten sie haben nur das
mitgenommen was für ihren fall wirklich
von belang ist und wenn es am ende
tatsächlich zu einem gerichtsverfahren
käme dann steht in rhede ob donald trump
für so etwas strafrechtlich verfolgt
verurteilt werden könnte und dann
vielleicht auch nicht mehr in der lage
wäre sich um ein amt in den usa zu
bewerben live aus washington el mati
wissen vielen dank